いません獅子たいことがあるんですけど締め社長のものの紛失についてどう思われます
か
うん
最悪ですおちんちん何回も何回もなくしてさらにそして人のせいにする
えっ
あっはぁどれぐらいの頻度でなくされるんですかシェイ
10アクサものあーなくそのカギは例大祭不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
インタビューですか
肇社長のものなく種ってどれくらい酷いですか
一番ひどいのは家の鍵めっちゃなくして最初に住んでた大学にあと4回公開
シンポジウム
鍵返したんじゃないかかいいなおしいくるおじさんと
友達になっててあ今日もですか王道のねコンビニっこんにちははじめそうですものを
なくすという行為皆さんしたぞと上げますでしょうかあのー
自慢じゃないんですけども僕ほどものをなくす人はそうそういないと思いますその小
学校の頃からたが始まっていたんですけど別個から家に帰った時に気付いたんですけど
もランドセルを忘れてました彼にももう宿題とかも9
を忘れるしてとりあえず
[音楽]
バカなんですでもこのとずになっても忘れ物ひどすぎて最後もなくてし家の鍵もなくて
し本当にものな曲がヒドすぎるあの多分皆さんが想像している何倍も僕はものをなくし
てますそんな僕がもいろんな鍵を持っているわけですよ
車の鍵静岡の湯の滝東京の鍵スタジオの鍵バイクの鍵
チャリの鍵とか全部の鍵を一つにしてるんです
けどもうこれ空もナッツ
こんなまま様ぜじゃあどうてでは鍵を無くさない数向かって考えたときに型ホールだと
いうもの皆さんつけると思うんですよ
鍵に何かコストラップとかものをつけると目立つし大きくなるから結構なくする確率は
かなり減ると思うんですけどもそのサイズでも1日12回はなく住んでなんと8戦だ
何度かせねばと思ったので今回キーケイ素もっとでかくしようと思いますどうで学習を
かという
いうとやっぱりキーホルダーをつけていくしかないと思うんですけどなるべく大きけれ
ば大きい程小保方の鍵をなくて釣れると思うので今回はキーホルダーなるべく買おうと
思います何個か祝い花僕ちょっとわからないんですが大きければ大きいほどいいと思う
んで
その大きさ皆さんに決めていただきますというわけでまたツイッターでつぶやきます
ライ角さん規模3ツイートされた数塩分キーホルダー
たくさん買いますで線リツイートだと1000円分のキーホルダーを買う
まあ要するにこれ t とされればされるほど僕が鍵を失くす確率減るのでむしろ
プラスなんですよあり方がありがたい皆さんのご協力で僕の棒の失くしが軽減されると
いうもう win-win の関係ですよや釣り上げますはい
[音楽]
やってたやったんだよって行ったやっぱいいよね
やったやったぁー現時点で今373円分ですねああやばい985になっちゃう
あー1000円超えました1000超えました時間がだいたい今日の夕方までにします
ああ今2000円ですね山田2600円2600 dt とだったら2600円なんで
多分がゴロっ子がな
まあまあなくさに頭くらい3000
んですね3000円だとまぁまぁそこそこ多いなあくらい
まだまだです
今彼がのうのうとカレーパンを食べている間でさえ
リツイート数を飲み続けているのであった
小島なんと3分前でございます5時ぴったりでリツイートし見切ってその値段分かい
ますのでもうしばしお待ちください
ん
茶
飛車の子連れ風味はいはいだけど今のリツイート数の分解ます
こちらの
するとアクティブで表示これでちゃんと出るはずです
[音楽]
ん
なんということでしょうかつて
あっさんが小さかって聴いちゃうん
ここまで変化しましたん
まあ特例
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ
別にと数が5万1704ずさあ作れちゃった
うそ
51,000750へもうこれで決定ですねやはりパッド増えて